demand for free food handouts just keeps
going up
basics for people to help themselves to
no questions asked
i do this
but with predictions the cost of living
crisis is going to get worse organisers
say it's now not just the next meal
parents are worried about
what we've seen is that the people want
to kind of not hoard but have extra
rations at home what we've had is that
the
parents want more food for them for
their children because they're always
worried about what is going to come in
next week
but for some the fear of not being able
to feed their children has already
become a reality
sultana begum is a single mother on
benefits with two young children
there have been times she admits they've
had to go hungry and they wouldn't
survive now without the food bank and
her family
that sense of foreboding hangs in the
air you don't have to look far to find
people who are struggling
we're embarking in east london and this
is not an isolated town in need
debra is on her own with a teenage
daughter and 10 year old son she pretty
much has no spare money to pay for
anything other than food and clothes let
alone family activities
it does feel awful
knowing that i can't do a lot of things
apart from everyday things that they're
supposed to do like going to school
and stuff but i want to have fun with
them
i know deep down that they want more
from me
deborah is using a hot meal service
which started just a few weeks ago with
10 people it's now packed
are feeding a lot more people by the day
and our cooker as you can see is not
commercial size no more and we can't
cold
but even with these handouts and we
can't know for sure organizers estimate
at least half the children they're
feeding are malnourished a lot of them
from uh from my experience i've noticed
were missing out on school simply
because they weren't healthy enough they
would get tired in their games football
they weren't able to run around and
they're just not able to afford enough
food
everything is eating up money and even
in the local laundrette where energy
prices have pushed up costs parents tell
us of the impact on their children
you sort of think i can't afford to wash
their clothes yep that's true before we
used to wash our clothes in about three
times a week
so now probably you have to make sure
you have to wash twice a week can't
afford yeah all the washing power
their condition everything is high
it all seems relentless with the
youngest in society growing up through
the worst cost of living crisis in a
generation issa holland sky news barking